la végétation aquatique indigène est
indispensable à l'alimentation et à la
reproduction de la faune aquatique mais
que se passe-t-il sous la glace durant
l'hiver on en sait encore peu des
chercheurs tentent donc de comprendre
l'influence réciproque des herbiers et
des glaces notamment lors des crues
printanières
[Musique]
avoir ces motoneigistes circulaient sur
les glaces du lac St Pierre on pourrait
croire à une excursion de loisirs
mais il s'agit en fait de scientifiques
biologiste géographe de la sologue et
expert en télédétection
ils se sont donnés rendez-vous sur la
surface gelée de cet immense lac
fluviale dont la profondeur de chaque
côté de sa voie navigable excède
rarement les deux mètres en fait en ce
moment on est au-dessus d'un herbier
dans très grand derbiers
et le directeur de cette mission de
recherche un projet qui soulève à ce
moment-ci beaucoup plus de questions que
de réponses
vous savez il y a des études qui partent
sur les effets de la glace au moment de
la débâcle sur les plantes de la zone
littorale on voit des des abrasions sur
les arbres mais on sait très peu ce qui
se passe au niveau donc des Herbiers
[Musique]
parmi les plantes submergées qui
l'intéresse la valise nérides d'Amérique
et l’étéranteurs litigieuse qui poussent
en eau peu profonde comme c'est le cas
où lac Saint-Pierre
à terme cette vaste opération de
collecte de données permettra aux
chercheurs de mieux comprendre l'impact
de l'évolution et des mouvements des
glaces sur cette végétation sous-marine
comment la lumière du soleil
arrive-t-elle à se frayer un chemin
jusqu'au plantes sous le couvert de
glace
commencez plantes aquatiques
influencent-elles la solidité de la
glace enfin cette végétation joue-t-elle
un rôle dans la formation d'un bacle
la glace et les herbiers les deux
ont une préférence on peut dire comme ça
pour les zones peu profondes à la fin de
courant et les plantes en fait vont
réduire
ultérieurement les courants donc vont
quelque sorte favoriser la formation de
la glace ça pourrait avoir une
conséquence sous qui tout ce qui est
accumulation des glaces au moment de la
débâcle donc c'est là qu'il pourrait
avoir une relation avec les inondations
les embarques les inondations sont chose
courantes ici le printemps ou durant les
épisodes plus fréquents de redoue il y a
des phénomènes de réchauffement au
milieu de l'univers et donc ces
phénomènes-là peuvent causer des débats
hivernales on se questionne sur le futur
donc de la relation entre glace herbiers
et des bacles dans un scénario de
changement climatique
donc on mesure l'épaisseur de la glace
la qualité de la glace on prend des
mesures donc aériennes donc il y a des
drones qui volent en ce moment il y a
des mesures satellitaires de la glace
et pour savoir ce que notre satellite
mesure vraiment la glace qu'on veut
mesurer mais il faut venir sur le
terrain pour essayer de quantifier cette
place là puis vraiment s'assurer valider
dans le fond ce que le satellite
une des façons de valider ça c'est
justement ce qu'on a amené des drones
sur lequel on a des GPA des grandes
pénétrer qui nous permet justement de
mesurer la spatialement les personnes de
la glace avec pardon
grâce entre autres aux archives
satellitaires on va donc reconstituer
l'historique de la glace sur le lac
Saint-Pierre ces mouvements sa
composition au fil du temps
puis ensuite on a des étudiants qui vont
faire le lien entre cette glace là
mesurée par satellite et puis les les
mesures de type de végétation aquatique
dans le fond du lac non quelques mètres
plus loin une autre équipe est à
moi mon expertise ici c'est vraiment la
glace donc c'est d'aider à comprendre
les processus de formation de glace on
va le voir avec les mesures donc les
carottages établir le stressigraphie de
la glace la glace blanche qui met
beaucoup de bulles d'air ça a été mis
rapidement la lumière mais c'est aussi
juste pour comprendre le mode de
formation de la glace ou la Saint Pierre
pour bien comprendre le lien entre la
végétation et la glace il faut d'abord
bien comprendre le cycle de la glace on
va compléter ça par des mesures
géophysiques donc on là on a un radar ou
qu'on va traîner derrière une motoneige
et on va croiser ça avec les données
qu'on obtient en été
laissé la caméra pour voir s'il y a des
si on peut voir des plantes dans la
glace dans le fond
et commencer par regarder sur le bord de
la glace
les petits fragments
ce qu'on sait déjà c'est que les
activités industrielles et agricoles
dans le bassin versant du lac
Saint-Pierre mais tempérer la végétation
indigène et cette tendance s'accélère
ces dernières années
on sait que la qualité de l'eau en été
intervient beaucoup sur cette
décroissance de la végétation
maintenant l'hiver c'est comme un trou
noir donc c'est vraiment des
connaissances de base aller chercher sur
quel est le rôle de la glace sur la
disparition des Herbiers
ces plantes submergées assurent pourtant
l'équilibre de la vie aquatique dont la
perche chaude une espèce emblématique
mais aussi menacée
donc vous voyez ici qui est une partie
qui est plus claire en fait on l'appelle
la glace noire c'est qu'il laisse passer
la lumière ici vous avez une portion
qu'on appelle la glace blanche qui est
en réalité bloque la lumière donc la
proportion des deux pour nous est
importante pour comprendre avoir une
idée de qu'est-ce qu'il passe comme le
mien pour les plantes qui sont en
dessous donc ce qui se passe c'est
l'hiver aura-t-il une conséquence sur
l'été ça c'est la des questions qu'on se
pose on trouve des zones dépourvues de
végétation de plaisirs en fait sont sont
réduits fortement
bien sûr l'ADN peut bouger donc cette
expert du ministère de l'Environnement
participe lui aussi à ce projet de
recherche si on allait dans les années
début des années 2000 on mettait une
caméra dans l'eau et on observe à peu
près 75% de chance ce qu'on observait de
la végétation aquatique maintenant
aujourd'hui c'est 25% de chance d'en
observer
pour mieux comprendre ce qui se passe le
biologiste et son équipe analyse des
échantillons d'eau prélevés sous les
glaces du lac Saint-Pierre
c'est échantillons lorsqu'on va pouvoir
faire avec eux mais c'est de développer
l'ADN environnementale sur les herbiers
aquatiques quelle espèce exactement
qu'on a tout ça ça va nous permettre
éventuellement de savoir comment le
restaurer mais il faut comprendre
comment la glace peut influencer les
herbiers
si par exemple dans les endroits où il y
a plus de végétations ça favorise la
croissance de glace
il y aurait il y aura un lien de cause à
effet entre végétation et inondations
printanière
à cette étape si c'est encore de la
spéculation ce sont des hypothèses
en interrogeant donc les riverains du
lac Saint-Pierre on se rend compte que
il substorne la gestion de la glace
comment facteur éventuellement en cause
dans l'évolution des herbiers de savoir
est-ce qu'il a gestion qu'on fait donc
en brisant préventivement les glaces va
affecter de façon positive ou négative
sans laisser pas encore l'évolution de
ces herbiers là
les premiers résultats de cette grande
collecte hivernale de données ne seront
pas connues avant le printemps 2024
la mise en commun de toutes ces
expertises devraient permettre d'affiner
les stratégies afin de mieux protéger la
biodiversité exceptionnelle de ce grand
bassin d'eau douce très fragile l'un des
derniers sites de pêche commercial du
Saint-Laurent à terme ce qu'on voulait
c'est surtout aider à restaurer les
écosystèmes du lac Saint-Pierre
l'habitat de la perche chaude entre
autres un joyeux de diversité écologique
et qu'il faut protéger mais pour le
protéger il faut aussi mieux le
comprendre
[Musique]